the jurogan experience it's just amazing
you know on paper
i was telling i was starting them out
there like on paper
on paper you put down my stats no one's
gonna pick me in a fight
what the [ __ ] is this guy [ __ ] next
you know what i mean
but then but then there's one thing
there's that there's that mental part
and and that hard part that you can't
measure you can't measure the mint or
whatever
no and that's that crazy land part you
know what i mean like people don't know
what the [ __ ] crazy land is so
if they see this guy like okay well he
got a passport to crazy land but this is
his stats
all [ __ ] you know out of 10 like
threes and this is the guy he's like
nine
nine all nines but he or maybe a couple
of tens in there but he don't have a
password to crazy and they'll be like
[ __ ] crazy land this guy is great
and then when you go in there you like
you find out that [ __ ] most of the time
the guys with the passport the crazy
lads is uh
they're crazy you know they figure out a
way to win they figure it out yeah
like you the sum of all your parts is
not that
like it that doesn't equal a
championship fighter
like the mind is such an important part
important and
and i was uh i was talking to them
outside back to that conversation i was
telling them like
whenever i talk to an opera comer or or
my friends or i see people training
and they're training hard or doing this
and that and i'm just like oh this is
crazy like
like most of us in the ufc already right
i was like guys
there comes a point where like you're
pretty much good like everything can get
you by you got here already
but now the only thing different that's
going to get you to the top 15
is mental and then from 15 to 10 the
only difference between those guys
is mental and then from from 10 to 5
same thing and from champion and
everybody else it's a mental
it's a mentality thing is this something
that to do with iq and something that's
the only thing it changed like
we're all good we're all at the mecca of
fighting the ufc is where
everybody wants to be but what makes you
a champ what makes me a champion you not
something i'd be it like you can live
more ways than me though you know what i
mean like we're the same if we're the
same weight class
you're stronger than me you're faster
than me what is the difference what is
the difference it
i i believe it's it's that passport
crazy land is that mental is that
is that thing like i'm willing to do
something that i don't know
if you even thought of doing it or if
it's presented with you that if you're
gonna take that chance you know
and it's it's that but it's also you're
willing to put
the intensity into your training camps
and the focus and dedication
into your craft that maybe some people
aren't and maybe sometimes people that
are really talented
things come a little too easy for them
and they don't want to work as hard
exactly that's the that's the downfall
with a lot of these guys you know a lot
of these guys is like
they're just like all-stars in their
town and playing regular sports you know
i mean you see it all the time there's
all-stars in towns whatever then they go
to the other stuff and then they're just
another guy yeah
there's somebody that's faster stronger
and better than you you know i mean and
then
when they get there instead of pushing
through they they never had to
and then there's that kid that was like
just always just kind of made the team
and then he's there with you and he sees
that and he see you break and that
pushes him
and now he's about he's with those guys
that's just who's those guys who's
freak athletes but they all have the
mind but this guy don't have the freak
at least but he get the mind and he's
hanging with him
because he's figuring out a [ __ ] way
to do it you know yeah some of the
toughest guys are younger brothers of
tough guys
oh yes oh yeah because you had to take
the [ __ ] yeah you gotta take
the [ __ ] you know i mean like it is like
they become
durable yeah it was it was kind of
backwards uh growing up with my brother
like i'm the middle child but
my brother's four years older than me my
older brother my my younger brother is
uh
one year younger than me but so it's
kind of backwards like it wasn't like
my older brother wasn't really tough on
us but it was a point where my younger
brother was like such a spoiled little
prick
that he would always get me into trouble
from uh from my grandma like he would do
my grandma and grandpa so like he would
do something and he'd cry and be like no
i did it so i would get the lickins you
know so i think so that's when my
mentality came by like i always i was
like [ __ ]
young so like even like even when i
fight with my younger brother he would
beat me because he's like i was smaller
than him like he beat me up growing up
and
the funny thing is is like i told you
last time is that every time uh
when my mom when i started getting the
kickboxing and my mom was telling people
like hey let's go
um my son's gonna go watch fight uh he's
gonna go fight this week he wanna buy
tickets they'll be like
oh cool who is clinton fighting and then
they'd be like oh no clem's not fighting
max's and they're like what the [ __ ]
like max don't fight
like you know i'm here like what the
heck why is he fighting
where is he fighting you know but it
comes because i just freaking
i got [ __ ] so abused and stuff i
never thought of that you just pointed
out to me like my grandma and grandpa
would give me
like this guy could get he would get
away with murder and i always got it and
then whenever he do something stupid
like outside we play with our friends
it's like there's a place on our street
where we couldn't pass
and my grandpa would like just be
sitting on the gazebo and catch my
my brother coming back and being like
because he would go in the [ __ ] main
road it's so stupid there's a dirt road
i was like bro take the dirt road like
grandpa's always up there drinking his
beer
take this damn dirt road so we don't
want to get into trouble he's like nah
nah nah god i'm not gonna be there
but i know all after all these years i
put together my [ __ ] winter world
because he wanted to see me get lickins
so after the time he's like max made me
to
go with them i didn't want to go and i'd
end up getting lickins they'd wrap me up
i was like bro i didn't
you told me gold what are you talking
about like
the table's his turn you're a little
[ __ ] bro what is he like now
he just uh he's crazy you know he's uh
uh he
um we we had to deal with some stuff
like uh
i you know my family and stuff would
come from drugs and whatever my mom and
stuff and except for my grandma grandpa
it's great for them
but he got into his trouble and stuff
but he's recently like he's been out
he's been clean
he's been doing his thing so i i'm proud
of him i'm happy
so it's like it's not i always tell him
too you know it's not how you start the
race is how you finish bro it's like
finish strong bro you got kids you got
focus now i know i know you
you think you [ __ ] up but you never
let nobody down yet you know you got you
got time
and just make everything right again or
try to go get as close
as you can to making everything ready
that's great advice that you still have
time
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience